vous viendrez peut-être passer une
journée ici cet été nous sommes à la
guinguette deux hommes à deux pas du
plan d'eau l'an dernier les tables et le
bar était déjà là avec plus de 30000
visiteurs mais cette année la guinguette
s'étoffe un bar plage un parc est
modulable en restaurant ou en salle de
danse et une scène de concert face à la
baignade
son nom les farmers et avec le bar snack
qui est ouvert tous les jours et le
restaurant est ouvert du mardi au
dimanche
donc la semaine uniquement le soir et
les week-ends midi et soir avec des
produits faits maison du terroir et à ce
pass 1 10% locale
l'autre nouveauté ici c'est le parc
aquatique il est géré par la guinguette
une structure gonflable et surveiller
pour les plus de 6 ans qui sera ouverte
tout l'été
le concept est allemand et ne s'étaient
déployés que dans le sud de la france
comme sur ces images
désormais le parc aquatique et donc
inédit en région centre
propriétaire du plan d'eau depuis 1981
le conseil départemental a décidé de
miser sur cet espace naturel sensible
il y avait un potentiel important qui
n'était pas très exploité ce n'était pas
les chefs de la communauté de communes
c'était vraiment un projet départemental
c'est pour ça qu'on fait le projet à un
million deux c'est pour les gens du
secteur bien sûr on a vu des personnes
qui venaient de tours de villandry c'est
pour des touristes est également on
pourra mettre je dirais des camping cars
autres aménagements réalisés au
printemps des aires de jeux pour les
enfants un terrain de beach volley de
pétanque et la mise en place d'une
signalétique en 2018 sera érigé une
station d'épuration pour traiter l'eau
de la zone de baignade tout et
installations pourraient permettre aux
touristes d'allonger la durée de leur
séjour
le château de gizeh et de langeais étant
tout proche puis se fait marcher aussi
le commerce local et ça favorise aussi
l'essor de l'économie touristique sur le
sur le territoire les premiers à se
jeter à l'eau lors de l'inauguration du
parc aquatique qui sera facturé 8 euros
de l'heure le président de notre
département qui chute et l'un des
candidats aux législatives
battu par son adversaire